okay playing abec one two three i'll
play a london
try for something solid
i've yet to win a game this stream
let's play a super solid london let's
play um i usually play knight c3 i'll
play e3 and
knight f3 like the og kamsky london
h3 bishop e2
[Music]
c3 oh
[Music]
i already messed up the move order maybe
i was supposed to play knight d2 sooner
but this should be okay queen b3
i guess we're like bishop e6 we trade
queens
and get some slightly imbalanced
structure
so black has a file the thread is
probably to take the pawn
[Music]
um
a4
like the idea of a4 and bishop
b5 comes from mind
that's actually you think okay and
talking about all of your moves to an
audience has made you a better chess
player at all
um i don't think it's harmed me
it's definitely made me a better
communicator
and maybe a better like public speaker
it's like growing up playing chess it's
a pretty solitary game where you don't
like
you don't interact at least in
like traditional chess but streaming in
chess
there's definitely been benefits to
other types of skills
and sometimes when i stream and talk
through my moves it holds me accountable
to
be reasonable and to think um like think
a bit more deeply than i otherwise would
good question though now if i play b3
there's knight d5
i play bishop d1 kind of passive
but maybe necessary
thanks for so much great content aside
from the london are there any other
openings named after cities
oh almost certainly right
rio i want to say reykjavik but that's
not uh
there's icelandic gambit oh there's
budapest
budapest berlin yeah chat knows better
than me
am i losing a pawn here
i could just yolo my rook but
i'd rather not lose material if this
there's b6
and then b4
i'm gonna have to check this line
afterwards because kopsky usually plays
these uh these structures
i think i've done something wrong oh no
my structure is going to fall apart very
soon
this is why i didn't play b3 but i
forgot that
b4 causes the same problems
if i take how bad is this let's take
also what happened to my time
okay i'm clearly like much worse here
but i want connect four
if it takes i have to take back
just trying to roll with the punches
jaybird getting merch thank you jaybird
okay gonna try and stay focused to
predict what black will do
yeah with that i think i can take again
or no
[Music]
it might be one
knight p1 is so ugly but it does defend
the pawn
also sets up for the next game
yeah i'm gonna have to live on the
increment
most of the rest of the game
anytime that i can grab the bishop here
get a better structure but my pawns
defended this pawn is offended
ooh fancy
i don't even know craft to take
i think the knight wants to redevelop
yeah that way if takes takes a pawn
still defended
i'm weirdly surviving here
like these pawns are all kind of weak
let's castle
and push because
oh that's a fork though let's play this
move
so if takes takes i lose a pawn but we
get
off the card bishops so if knight takes
i play bishop d5
that's a good move have to play this
probably
still in some trouble
down upon
the b-pawn is going to be annoying
i want to play rook b1 the rook was
babysitting the bishop
are you 95 at some point rookie 3 is
probably a threat
uh let's pin now i want to play rook c3
even knight d2 knight g2 is a nice idea
and bishop d4 let's try it
might just trade a lot
might take wait what
take here light still pinned
if bishop takes i play rook c2 i
probably went back upon c4
and then maybe hold on for a draw
with three seconds left
i want to play king g2 and unpin
surviving i'm not down material i'm
losing oh now i'm
losing material this move i want to play
this move and
rook c7
also restricting the knight oh i had
this move
i'm still threatening that though
yeah i think i had a chance to win
material there i'm still threatening
this
ooh um
let's play this
let's not hang a rook am i meeting
it'll be the most random knight e5 rook
f7
okay let's come back almost kind of
sort of play this move
yeah so h5 is coming
check what is this
to play this
i'm still worse
bring my knight back to the center or
bring my king up into the center
play this and win a pawn
oh no black can take my pawn
uh let's take a pawn
and push what is this game
joe let's go
97 was forcing the fork
okay i should be winning this now how am
i winning this
wow i want it let's go what's that game
need some sheep noises
ah what was that game
so in this position actually i i had
bishop e2
which i saw only after i played bishop
b5
a bishop e2 drives the rook away from
defending the bishop
and it wasn't just one material because
i'm controlling these squares
controlling all the squares where they
can still defend the bishop
oh so i have the same idea so knight d7
knight g7 is actually a really cool move
because the king has five legal moves
all of them lose a rook bach either has
to walk into a discovery
so these moves walk into
knight c5 winning the rook and these
moves
walk into knight f6 with a fork
so hopefully that makes sense so some
cool like geometrical pattern um
but then what happened in the game i
lost all my pawns
actually this pawn was poisonous it was
the same idea
knight e7 and the king either has to
walk into the discovery
um on the 7th or the fork with knight g6
so get some nice arrows here
that's the benefit of having like a
really active rook and knight
against the king that's cut off on the
back rank
oh why do i always end up well so this
game
i spent a lot of time in the opening
because i played something a bit
different
and i just got in under early pressure
i don't know maybe taking is wrong
or maybe what i should do
yeah c3 is already slightly inaccurate
um
[Music]
what does kopsky play
what does carlson play how about just
castles
oh wow so white can sack the pawn on v2
wow so this is carlson mvl
2017. um
carlson just doesn't care about his
b-pawn so if takes
i assume knight c4
wait what knight c4 queen b5 best engine
move
walking into this discovery in 96
i feel like more people would play queen
c3
but then rook b1 threatening the queen
trap that's kind of cool
nice idea to keep in mind
yeah i usually don't play the sign but
uh nice to
take my rating to be aware of this idea
oh i think you and your tap sometimes
when you switch up
lines even within like an opening that
you usually play
uh it still takes some experience to
to be aware of the the nuances
like now i know to castle first and just
delay c3
because usually like when black takes
you take with e pawn anyway
to keep the structure against the bishop
so there's no big reason to play c3 so
soon